I have here in my hands
the one chip challenge do not eat if you
are sensitive to spicy foods allergic to
Peppers nightshades or capsizing or are
pregnant or have any any medical
conditions at all Keep Out Of Reach of
children after touching the chip wash
your hands with soap and do not touch
your eyes or other sensitive areas seek
medical assistance should you experience
difficulty breathing
fainting or extended nausea Jake Michael
how you feeling I told you when we
talked last time when we made this bed
that I go through with my bets I wear a
straight jacket yesterday for an hour
and a half on the show that was kind of
like a Biden Administration straight
Jackie yeah I mean it was 50 Shades of
Jake to be honest with you okay so I'm
I've just got a suit up properly so I
just opened it up to be honest with me
just the smell hit me it's like like
smelling salts it hit me
oh my gosh you're in the Hazmat suit
this is not good
okay
okay hold on
oh this is good
God made a huge mistake Mr Crane
it's always a pleasure congrats on the
win now I have here a series of
questions to test your focus and resolve
okay when you eat that chip fist bump uh
friendship let's go bro let's go man all
right here we go guess what three three
four coming at you no lips that's what
they said
[Music]
all right Jake
first question
first question
is cereal a soup for stew
it's so bad
is it a what
is cereal a soup or a stew
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's a stew
who oh my gosh who is this oh my gosh
Michael who was the second President of
the United States
[Music]
Madison
no John Adams John Quincy Adams no that
was a he was a later oh that was that
was that was his evil brother there's
more there's more levels okay all right
oh it's in there Michael believe me let
me see can I see your tongue oh my gosh
how bad is it how bad is don't you look
at me Bill yeah okay let's go with the
questions Michael I'm dogging it right
now will you admit I'm dogging it will
you admit you were wrong about Jimmy G
oh
for to get through this yes I would
admit that I was wrong about Jimmy G but
I was also right about Trey Lance bro I
can't believe when I I had a little dust
on my tongue I took milk within 10
seconds I'm telling you I'm look I'm
doing it for the city oh my city on my
back bro I'm crying
why don't you like marshmallows it's
because they're because I'm not
communist
aha
it's so bad everybody out there don't do
it don't do it
don't do it don't do it for the children
this probably will resonate with you
right now
we all make mistakes but did you or did
you not vote for Obama in 2008.
I'll plan for whoever y'all want man
I'll vote for whoever y'all want is this
is how they got the this is how they got
it out of the terrorists this is how we
found out baghdadi I did not vote for
Obama yep had not done this to Khalid
Sheikh Muhammad sooner oh gosh we know
where there would have been zapping way
more of those terrorists oh he'd be
ready he'd be running in Wisconsin so if
you had to fire one of your co-hosts why
would it be blamed how would you tell
him speaking of terrorists
[Music]
because I knew I could still take care
of them and
because he should have let the kids go
oh Michael it's so bad
[Music]
it's so bad I'ma make it through it Alex
Stein is not better than me
look look at I mean you were dude I
can't Michael I can't explain it I can't
explain it I am flaming Dragon right now
I'm seeing I am fighting dragons tears
are are pouring out of your eyes my face
hurt so bad my throat
[Music]
I got a question for you what's your
beef with Vincent van Gogh and is it
because she's white because uh of course
but abstract painting we all know
means this painting sucks and Vincent
van Gogh I feel like I could do better
paintings that's why none of his sold
during his time because they all
realized it was trash but but but
he's a lot better than Jackson
well and like Vincent van Gogh you know
he cut his ear off I could see you
cutting your tongue off right I will cut
anything well everything but one thing
everything but one thing everything but
one thing Michael it is so
I get it now I get it now yeah I get it
now and I get it now I need to know will
producer Justine ever find love
now she keeps me herself
[Music]
am I through it you're not through it
you could make one person eat this what
would it be
just for comedic effect John fetterman
oh my God
oh my God
have you ever relieved yourself in a
bathroom sink just because uh yeah I got
kicked out of a bar in college yeah I
think we all ah I think that's that's
like a rite of passage right yeah
especially when the line is too long and
there's someone paying for all my
mistakes yeah I'm paying for all my reed
I love you Billy I love you Moga I love
you oh and Molly Gal Gadot or Margot
Robbie oh both
all right that's both that's it'll
really be nice Michael it's getting
worse yeah like you know me we're
friends yeah I I could I I don't for
context man when I when I just took a
little of the Dust it ruined like 20
minutes of there was like 20 minutes I
had milk right away
uh why can't you admit that sticker is
on college football helmets don't count
because decals and stickers are
different
he goes and stickers are different
last question oh man here we go please
don't draw this out ask a question ready
for the okay what was the title of my
best-selling book all the good ideas by
the Democrats and it had nothing in it
wow that is pretty close
a history of the best Democratic ideas
that's further away
uh
you're close am I close but don't but I
also have two best
how I kill Jay cranny got away with it
that's that's gonna be number three
congrats so I think wow you made it
through all of the questions Jake how
was your time on that Crane and Company
Craig bro you held up for six minutes
oh oh
[Music]
oh
man
That's The champ is here Michael
The champ is here
ah I am so glad I won that football game
oh Michael that's can I tell a funny
story before you go please
you wanna know how Michael knows the
real one sorry for getting milk
everywhere
laughs
yeah
edge of focus all right when you were
coming in the other day on Monday yeah
you remember when we passed each other
yeah yeah and you looked at me and I was
like congrats on the win and you were
like I don't have to eat the chip yes
that hit in the way I don't think you
really understood but for that minute we
were one together yeah yep that hit and
you and you took it and that's hitting
me right now right
high five for friends way to go man
thank you pride and Company
[Music]
my face started like leaking yeah it
feels so bad